this album is a celebration it's it's
fun from top to bottom and it must mean
something special to you was it in the
works before you were involved in Mamma
Mia no I didn't even think it came out
of nowhere I mean honestly I didn't plan
it I didn't think about it I did the
movie I did Fernando and the beginning
of Super Trouper and I don't know what
happened
honestly one day I just thought really
be fun to do a cover album and I've
never thought that in my entire life
yeah and and I couldn't even imagine
matching two people or two groups less
alike than me and album yeah so why now
and and why this for a cover album you
say you've never thought about that
before ever it was it just something you
thought this is gonna be a lot of fun to
do what was it no I just thought I might
like to do this but I don't now it seems
so far away mm-hmm
the moment I thought about it I was
gonna go on vacation I was had a lot of
things to do and somehow I thought I
might try singing another Abba song
that's really what happened
I didn't think oh I'm gonna make the
album so I did one of us mm-hmm and my
managers heard it and I had marked there
at my house and we had you know all the
different songs that we just had looked
out and thought oh that's a good idea
that's a good idea that's a good idea
and then I did one of us and then they
played it for the record company and
they just said do what you want yeah
which song when you were belting it out
did it feel right what felt like oh yeah
this is that this is getting me in the
groove well one of us for sure and
Chiquitita I really yeah yeah I just
love it and and you know I like Mamma
Mia - it makes me laugh and and they're
you know I mean I think on the album the
songs are done so differently you know
each there's not one that's like the
other it's like we put out gimmi gimmi I
thought
god this doesn't this is not like any of
the other songs you know it's really
electron it's completely electronic and
and because you know it's it's it then
like if you like all the songs are
different you know I I think they go
together well but none of them are like
they're like cousins they're not like
brothers and sisters yeah it's been five
years since your last new album she's a
whole new album what provoked you to
think about doing covers versus new
material because I didn't think about
doing and now a new album I mean I had
an idea for one but I wasn't serious
yeah and I think the fact that I didn't
think this through at all yeah you know
it just I just did it and I and I don't
think I was serious about doing it when
I started it but but they're very
they're much more complicated than I
think we you think about Abba records we
don't think much about them I know and
when I got well I've kind of got it from
Fernando but I realized that Benny's
been he's really good and these riffs
are like all over the place and going
one inside another it's you know and and
Bjorn's lyrics are great you got to kind
of get to them and in a way that is
different because he's not writing in
English so the way he manifests
storylines yeah it's different you know
well we've heard these songs for years
like my mom used to play ABBA
in our living room and that was kind of
like she's it's disco and we danced a
lot to it and certainly with the
resurgence of Mamma Mia but from your
point of view going into it and
recording these songs like again did you
learn something different about the
songs did you have to find that you took
a different approach to even how you
approach singing because of this no I
only had condemned who I am I only can
be what I'm seeing I can only be Sheriff
yeah so I kind of was fearless and
stupid I was too stupid to be afraid
okay you know so I just thought I'll do
this one and I did it and I'm like
it's it wasn't I knew it wasn't gonna be
a bar
yeah but it wasn't gonna not be ever you
know it was gonna be
I believe and I could be totally wrong
but I believe if you like ABBA it's just
a boy it's just ever again yeah you know
a lot of the Abbas music is a they sing
a lot about love but the good the bad
the ugly
are there any life and love lessons that
you would give out to people at this
point
oh my mother gave me a Oh some wisdom
that I've kept my whole life and it's if
it doesn't matter in five years it
doesn't matter and we always think that
this love is like the only love and and
we have to you know we we have we can
never give I don't believe you can give
up yourself you can't you know you can
be in love but you shouldn't fall in
love yeah you know and and and I mean
falling is not like falling is a
negative thing it just says I have no
control over anything I you know I am
just cascading into I don't know where
yeah so I think being in love is uh is a
gentle way of getting into a psycho
someone was asking me about different
boyfriends and I'm friends with all of
them and I think that I was I liked them
before I think that's something you have
to do I think you should like the person
you love right because then when you
break up if you don't like them you just
don't want to know that many more and I
always think that sad is love something
that you should actively be looking for
or you just should be open to it for
whenever it comes your way like even at
this point now I think that you just
have to be I don't know does anybody
find love looking for it hmm I mean I
know I mean I think that I think that
you just meet a person and it's and you
click I don't I mean I think you can be
open to it I just don't know if you can
be looking for it right
Mamamia fans were really quick to point
out that you and Amanda Seyfried had a
resemblance to the characters from Yes
Mother Gothel and in Rapunzel and now
they want it and now they're asking you
for it the clamoring for us so what's it
going to take to make this be a real
life movie I don't know when I saw the
picture I thought well I mean because
the pictures of us standing there and
the picture of them standing there it
was you know I thought well that's
really weird
I also believe what belongs to comes to
you so maybe it will